[Music]
you know how like all the fur on dogs
looks the same I so it could be like dog
pubes
like and you're just like petting their
pubes whatever they oh yeah my note
about the electric bill yeah I'll get
you back when I booked at Sleepy Hollow
job hi Brandon Xanadu Xanadu my little
brother son Renee we're gonna get
roaches if they don't bite I've been to
going shopping what else is so
depressing it's like all these moms and
yoga pants and carts filled with kale
only
[Music]
Britany it's not even my puke
that's worse I want to say with mom and
dad for the week I paid the rent through
the end of the month if you want to
renew the lease and you find a new
roommate you're moving out why is it
because Xanadu is your luffa is now well
[Music]
mom Edie
so much more hishis the window dream
came back together again
hey listen I just got all six seasons of
Kojak on blu-ray we're gonna have so
much fun
I saw your suitcase in the hallway
something happened was it toxic mold
it's a silent killer it's a note I'm
sick of mold I'm just staying here until
I can get up enough money to rent a
studio or something what did your sister
do to you you can tell me is she doing
drugs again no new ones
mom I am perfectly capable of taking
care of myself remember when you came
out of the closet I was just thinking
about it I know you're not busy Brandon
says you just lie around the house all
day reading your horoscope I have a very
important audition are you sure it's a
real audition this time that was one guy
one van one time no this is legit it's
for network TV do you want me to do
anything well you're already dead so no
so I'd be playing at that body
I mean it's cheaper than renting dummies
you're gonna have to learn how to do
this yourself I'm not gonna be around
forever look I don't think you want to
report to spam you know this Pam used to
come in and pan a story your Uncle Mike
and I were in Tijuana once eating
nothing but spam and peyote yeah you
spent the whole night in the hospital I
know you're stalling just click on him
okay good now click on report as spam
that's it
that's it now all emails from ruski baby
69 are gonna go to your spam box she
said she wanted to do sex with you it's
becoming very clear we're in boxes full
summer spam was this is a reason to
celebrate either bottle of whiskey I've
been saving for a moment like this I was
really upset about that feral cat that I
let live with us but it needed a home
and he was always saying stuff like stop
shaving your legs in the sinker I'm
gonna move out oh my god what if you
moved in
yeah we could like Jill's party Sharon
ah you know rents not really my thing
oh yeah yeah yeah no idea before I met
your mom I was shaking it up with this
go-go dancer named Shasta go on we used
to play this little game called escaped
convict and the wardens wife believed
that one old man what are you doing
cooking you and your father were having
so much fun last night so I thought we
could have a little tough how are you
doing mmm really I'm fine
supposed to get another email today
about a new temp job it's dad injury hmm
remember when you won that award for
being gifted and talented yeah that was
the fifth grade and then after college
when you started that fantastic bike
sharing business we're not talking about
this little early don't you think it's
noon and data entry
I like that entry I like temping it's
easy there's no commitment and they give
you bagels on Tuesdays yeah I know I
just thought you wanted more than that
but if you need to move in here
permanently when you figure things out
your father and I are happy to have you
okay okay Thank You bacon yes
not kosher anymore remember that faith
yeah
he's dating a juicer right I know
[Music]
[ __ ] it's even worse than I thought
what are you doing here a load of whites
and busting you out of this place before
you drink the kool-aid I'm actually
gonna stay a while for good
just until I figure out what I'm gonna
do next just come back already
Britney no I can't live with you you're
not an adult fine
good luck having fun a thumb down hey do
you know why they keep the bleach
assumed you use it up in your bottom
wall I'm hairless it's for your skin
idiot
you know Britney you're always welcome
to move home too yeah all right
maybe I'm dead so what are you going to
do about finding a new roommate oh why
don't you just have Santa do move in
advance
Xanadu that's Brittany's new girlfriend
Xanadu Xanadu very in demand DJ well
what kind of beat says she's been we
just want to make sure that you end up
with someone who's gonna take care of
you you know we met the nicest lesbian
looking at the bank shootin me a gym
teacher Jesus I'm not gonna date your
bank teller I know you guys all think
acting's one big joke but I think this
close to being a featured corpse and
Sleepy Hollow well sometimes things just
don't work out I wanted to be an
astronaut well I put my foot down and I
said no way
[Music]
and somebody was a better corpse than me
at least you're trying failing
constantly it's better than sitting in a
cubicle all day but the day I was
spilling coffee on myself I didn't
notice until he's burning me dripping
down my leg I said at this point in my
life things would be better yeah pretty
much
[ __ ] that was our thing you play no I
know you're trying to do you'll see it's
not so bad here is that bacon
[Music]
the thing with wrestling an emu is you
wanna yeah I could see that okay
princess
Geena Davis mom we're out of snacks no
more snacks before dinner it's taco
night Arriba
taco makes the best yeah that's your
phone as well a temp agency
hello so you are alive because when you
didn't respond to my last 50 emails or
something I'm sorry I haven't gotten any
emails from you oh they seem to have all
gone through my spam folder what Brandon
I need you to be better than this that
is so weird
why would all my emails go to this spam
folder help me block spam for my email
all the emails go straight to spam it's
still great having you here buddy
brueski baby can't find me Dada Dada boo
dad's been sabotaging me
and that's why mom's been cooking so
well they're trying to make us fat and
lazy so that we never leave bo do we
want to it's taco night it's always
gonna be a taco night gonna get more
than this
Mario Kart no look you're talented as
[ __ ] and I was a genius in the fifth
grade let's go home you want to live
with me again I gotta get my laundry Oh
God
come on Tommy Familia let's get this
party started
run please don't leave can't keep its
here forever I've got a 12 year old
Scotch with your name on it
on let's go
I think I went too far these emails
they'll be back do I have to just until
you get your big break or I win the
lottery
[Music]
hi I was wondering if you needed any
more temps yeah you got it
[Music]
can I've talked a night with two people
it's come to this
you